abigail bienvenida de por favor
cuéntenos que se está haciendo para la
evacuación de ciudadanos de ecuador y
cómo se está organizando esto
pues muy buenos días la verdad estamos
trabajando constantemente juntando de
evacuar a todos lados de la ciudad que
sinceramente llegan muchos ecuatorianos
baja muchísimo que quieren cruzar la
frontera y por desgracia por algún
motivo no nos dejan salir de portentosas
tratamos de ver cómo ayudamos a todos
pero la forma más cuenta posible hemos
recibido ya el día de hoy sólo hoy
transcrito como un 75 ecuatorianos
aproximadamente aquí no estamos en este
momento y
228 personas 22 para la ciudad
y 68 personas se fueron para un día por
medio de día primo
abigail además de esa cifra de cuántos
ecuatorianos estamos hablando a nivel
nacional en ucrania y en qué lugares
están ubicados
pues la mayoría de nosotros estamos
ubicados en la ciudad de libia pero de
hecho tenemos muchísimos ecuatorianos
otra cosa la frontera corpórea
muchísimos yo tengo un amigo que me
llama me llamó el día de alguien que
dice que tiene como 310 en la frontera
con polonia no nos permiten pasar están
a tener una ronda no me acuerde este
momento cómo se llaman tengo niños están
en la frontera por ejemplo de phoenix y
me dicen que hay una cosa que a veces
tienen que caminar como 15 kilómetros 30
kilómetros 4 del redil porque los coches
que tenemos nosotros que conseguimos con
taxistas que ellos voluntariamente van
hasta cierto punto porque si pasan desde
el punto nos pueden preso y los
mandan sinceramente a no sabemos dónde
entonces básicamente nuestro nuestro
plan es momento es tapar de manera algo
más cerca tanto la que se pueda ir ahí
los chicos tienen que caminar hasta la
frontera eso lo que podemos hacer en
este momento porque no tenemos más
opción estamos con las manos de una u
otra manera adaptadas para ayudar
hay algunos de ellos que vivan en el
este o en el sur de ucrania ellos
estarían en situación mucho más difícil
de alcanzar la frontera polaca o rumana
que quienes vivían al oeste de ucrania
ya han llegado allí por ejemplo
referente a esa unidad cuando comenzó la
crisis nuestra manera más exactamente el
domingo ya estoy perdida sinceramente
que ya estamos hoy pero creo que es una
semana tras una reunión en kiev donde
básicamente estuvo el cónsul luis
narváez ys y él se reunieron varios
ecuatorianos ipad puede comenzar a
practicarse la situación que les estaba
pasando y entonces es una misma decisión
por ciudad un delegado el cual es muy
control en aguantar yo que iba a tratar
naguanagua 30 está en contacto con el
cónsul para así de una manera tratar de
solucionar toda la situación y del día
martes eso por el 2002 inequívoco que el
día martes cuando comenzó el bombardeo
nosotros literalmente estábamos dormidos
todos y uno pero te jodes en mi ciudad
donde yo vivía infiel e invita
variaciones que estaban allí
inicialmente en ese momento comenzaba a
llover una cantidad de llamadas a cada
delegados que teníamos el presente
trabajo como 11 delegados al que estamos
cuatro delegados básicamente aquí
trabajando en inhibir y cuando el
acuerdo a todos entonces recibimos la
llamada de mucha gente preocupada y
literalmente comenzamos como llamadas a
la cancillería de conferencia
de esta manera para tratar de solucionar
toda la situación pero desgraciadamente
ya que el programa estaba muy serio y el
cuadro mandaron busca una ciudad es
decir muy complicado porque no habían
buses mediante ley de transportes
nosotros por ejemplo ayer de viaje
anteayer proxy a ser y anteayer logramos
es evacuar donde visitas más o menos nos
nueve ecuatorianos uruguayo y
básicamente para poder salir de odessa
extractar vivir la frontera con polonia
nos tocó pagar básicamente por persona
250 dólares porque no había más
habitables es muy temprano para
preguntar esto pero en algún momento
cuando termine toda esta situación
planean regresar a ucrania
a mí me gustaría la verdad porque estoy
en mi último año de periodismo hoy en mi
último semestre y literalmente preocupa
de esta situación no sé si lo voy a
terminar no sé si el periodista no sé
qué va a pasar de hecho a tener un mismo
problema con la mayoría de ecuatorianos
que quieren seguir estudiando pero por
motivo de la situación que estamos
viviendo no sabemos qué va a pasar con
estos estudios porque son documentos de
estudios tanto en la universidad y de
hecho hoy día el segundo contenido sobre
las tres horas atrás hubo un ataque que
tiene que ver con disparos en la ciudad
o de donde yo vivía en que están
constantemente allí siendo de una u otra
manera bombardeados casi cada día
entonces está complicada la situación
sinceramente no sabemos qué va a pasar
el día de mañana pero por el momento
estamos decidir gracias y lo día a día